welcome to another one of my dr sailor
chalk and talks this one is focused on
some
questions and issues that are arising in
the first week of my
online ethics class this summer i always
have my students
find some way and i this way i'm doing
it with forums
to raise some of the questions concerns
confusions that they have regarding
ethics
early on so that i can i can begin to
address them
otherwise they'll linger through the
entire semester and one of the things
that i find
every single semester every single class
without
fail not only in my ethics classes but
any classes where we're talking about
moral matters
are some issues some questions and
confusions
that come about because of not making
needed distinctions
one of the things that i think is most
important to
to grasp about not only ethics but
philosophy in general
and really really anything that involves
critical thinking
that is going to involve applying
concepts to reality
is that we have to be able to make good
distinctions
there's a there's a tendency to engage
in far too much abstract
all or nothing don't look at the the
particulars kind of thinking
and then when people do look at the
particulars they start getting all bound
up and admired in the details and they
can't see
how to apply the higher principles to
the actual cases
and they wind up stuck in all sorts of
questions confusions
concerns that leads to all sorts of
problems and
oftentimes this just constitutes a
roadblock
in a conversation it can turn into the
well
we don't really know anything kind of
kind of thing it can lead to the kind of
relativism
that is a go-to for many people as soon
as things start getting tough which we
don't want to get into if we actually
want to get anything done
thought-wise um
it blocks the road to progress it really
not only blocks the road to progress
intellectually for people
but because intellectual life and moral
life go
hand in hand and are connected up
together it holds people
back from fulfilling their potential as
human beings so i understand that's
rather grand scale
and we're going to focus on some things
that are a little bit more
mundane nitty gritty at this point but
that's worth keeping in mind
so there's a number of different places
or situations in which people
need to start learning how to make
distinctions
and i've only got three of these sort of
cases
up here and they overlap to a certain
extent but they they all
end up being the kinds of things that
not only students but anybody who's
really not that experienced with a
particular field
is likely to do when they start thinking
about it
when there's demands placed on them to
start thinking about things in a more
serious
deep follow it through kind of way so
what are these
one is asking only about the general
as if there's a one-size-fits-all
response
so saying is this x whatever
x happens to be all this way
or none of it or
do you have some rule that can apply in
every single case
is there some definition students are
always asking for definitions and
actually not just students but people in
conversation
they're always wanting to have
definitions and they don't realize that
definitions are something that we work
our way towards not something
that if you're a beginner you actually
want to start with they can actually
trip you up because you think that you
understand everything in the definition
or that the definition
fits every case equally well and then
when you find out that it doesn't
you're upset and we start getting to
some of these things down here which
i'll talk about in a moment
another very very common problem setting
up false dichotomies
saying well look it's either this or or
it's this
which is it and then you ask the expert
and the expert says well
it's really a mixture of both or you
know there's a continuum
or well actually it's neither one of
those you've kind of
got it wrong or you know in some cases
this in some cases that in some cases
something else
and again the beginner is very likely to
take this sort of response and say oh
wait a second i just want a straight
answer from you
and the expert will say well you're
asking for something
that really you don't have any any good
grounds to ask for because the reality
that we're dealing with is more
complicated that's why we got to make
distinctions
see distinctions allow us to divide
things up and to say
well look if you're talking about it
this way
then i can give you this answer but if
you're talking about it this way
then i have to give you this kind of
answer and there may be other things
that we've left
out you know and i'll come to talking
about you know the ins and outs of
distinctions in a moment
here's another third way people often go
wrong with this
i see this happening all the time
blurring together or conflating
different issues and positions or even
propositions
as if they're all the same or equivalent
or one necessarily leads to the other
and they're the in that case the
distinction that you want to make
is actually between those positions and
say look if you're asking this question
of me
well here's an answer to that but that
has nothing to do with the question over
here
that you're you're trying to you know
tie together with this
this is a separate question this is a
separate issue
and we have to look at this separate
from this one over here
answering this one may not give you an
answer to this one answering this one
may not give you an answer to this one
so these are things that i see students
doing over and over again
i myself have done them plenty of times
you know
becoming a good critical thinker or
doing moral philosophy well
is something that requires practice
practice
practice you have to keep doing it doing
it doing it you're going to screw up
but eventually you start to weed away
those kind of mistakes and you start to
develop the habit of making good
distinctions
and if you look at
classic philosophical texts or even if
you look at
contemporary analytic philosophy which
tends to be
a little bit you know removed from from
classical philosophical approaches to
things
what you find people doing is
analyzing things along the lines
where distinctions can be made and
saying
let's look carefully at this let's not
try to answer this question
immediately let's see whether there's a
lot of different ways
of looking at this and whether once
we've actually
separated out or classified these ways
whether they lead us to different paths
when you're making a distinction what
you're doing is you're saying
things are not the same that's what it
is for them to be
distinct from each other and
that can happen within the same thing so
for example let's look at some of these
examples that
have come from my my students works one
of the questions that comes up
every semester has to do with violence
and it usually comes up in terms of
capital punishment
a concrete political issue
but it can come up in a lot of other
frameworks as well you know
whether it's okay to if somebody treats
you badly to treat them badly in
response you know that's
that's analogous to that is it okay to
use force and self-defense or to protect
another person
so
what we want to do is try to avoid
asking questions set up like this
is it ever okay to use violence either
yes or no
and if we say well look you know people
say that that using force against other
people is wrong using violence is wrong
well it must be wrong entirely across
the board
well no that's not the way in which
people who are actually
working in fields that involve violence
like say policing
or people who are theorizing about it
say you know aristotle for example
thinking about
whether it's okay to use force to punish
that's not though that's not going to be
a very productive way of handling things
because that tends to lead to quandaries
like this
let's use capital punishment as an
example well you know it's not okay for
us to to put
murderers to death because then we're
just murdering them
well are you
lumping everything into the same
category without making
needed distinctions at that point i mean
regardless of how you feel about it you
should think to yourself
are these cases really the same in all
relevant respects
is it the same for a private citizen
to use deadly force kill another private
citizen
who they had no no good justification to
kill
is that exactly the same sort of thing
as the state then after uh you know a
process
of trial and you know understanding of
course that the trials can be subverted
and all that sort of thing but
is that the same thing as after having
given somebody a trial and having given
them an appeals
process using just the right amount of
force to kill them
somebody who actually killed other
people it's not exactly the same is it
once you start thinking about it a
little bit more concretely
but notice you have to do that you have
to get away from
thinking that it's all one single
amorphous
all the you know same equal across the
board
kind of phenomenon and you have to start
making
distinctions is it okay to
use violence against somebody who's
using violence against you
the question of self-defense um well
is that different is that a different
kind of situation is it distinct
from somebody who is say a sadist and
just wants to hurt other people
i would say yes those are distinct
situations now you may end up in the
same
you know answer ultimately and saying no
no it's still wrong all across the board
but until you make those cuts until you
analyze things you're not going to be
able to think through
whether these dissimilar cases really do
amount to the same thing
let's look at another one that comes up
all the time
with students um
many students labor under the assumption
that if there are objective standards of
right and wrong
they should be immediately clear to
everybody
and if they're not immediately clear to
everybody
then there are no objective standards of
right and wrong so what would this be
this would be a false dichotomy wouldn't
it it's saying
either there are objective standards of
right and wrong
and they are immediately intuitive or
evident to everybody and there therefore
everybody would follow them
which you know is not the case or
everybody's just got their own
individual perspective and there really
is no objective right and wrong there's
just subjective preferences or
opinions or experiences or life you know
pick whatever you like you know whatever
jargon you like over there
is that all there is could it could
there be other possibilities
could there be the possibility that
maybe there are
objective standards of right and wrong
but that it takes a lot of work
to be able to actually figure out what
they are
and to apply them correctly and to to
make you know
good judgments and difficult cases if
there's a third possibility
then you've got a false dichotomy and if
you've got a false dichotomy
and you stick to that false dichotomy
you are going to find yourself
stuck and unable to make any any
progress
you're probably going to make things
difficult for other people too if you're
called upon to make any
decisions that way a third one that
comes up which
really exemplifies this this third type
of blurring things together i realize
the case that we just looked at
also exemplifies that blurring things
together too
some people will say um
moral values opinions about right and
wrong
pick whatever you like in that sort of
category
experiences the bases on which we we
choose to make decisions
these are all individual sometimes
they'll say things like they're unique
to every individual which which is
clearly nonsense right because
if they were in fact unique to every
individual then
there couldn't be any discussion of them
whatsoever experiences
may to some degree be said to be unique
but moral values no there's a certain
array of them
and you may try to come up with
something new but whatever you pick
guaranteed plenty of other people have
picked that particular thing to orient
their moral decision making around
and so you're not unique that's just
nonsense that people tell themselves
because we live in a culture that wants
to preach that to us
be that as it may it is true that people
do have individual perspectives
that uh the same person like aristotle
points out
two thousand years ago does not always
necessarily
think the same things about the same
things particularly if they don't have
good moral character they're going to be
all over the map
so does that solve the issue of whether
morality
itself or you know moral values
themselves are all
purely subjective that's a different
question isn't it
it's one thing to say or to ask the
question
do people differ on moral issues
do they arrive at different moral
judgments do they begin from different
sets of values
have they had different experiences
that's one
set of questions it's an entirely
different animal
to say are
moral values purely subjective
or even if we want to go a little bit
further are they just relative to
societies or groups or
that sort of thing and if you blur these
questions together
if you're not careful in distinguishing
them
apart from each other and asking for
answers
separately from them then when you
answer one
you're going to think that you've
answered the other one you're going to
think that you've answered both
and that may not be the case so
you know why do i bring this up in these
particular examples because a lot of
students come to my classes
and frankly you know quite a few people
that i enter into conversation with
come to me with the views that
everything is just purely you know
subjective because
they've been misled by faulty reasoning
by not making distinctions distinctions
are one of the fundamental tools
of human thought if you're not willing
to make distinctions
you're not willing to think very far
you're only willing to think in
in very simplistic abstract terms if you
want to understand difficult matters the
sort of things that people do disagree
about
you have to be prepared to make
distinctions and to them to follow
through the different paths and see
where they lead to
now let's look at some of the reasons
why
people don't make distinctions when they
when they need to be making distinctions
in order to think things through
why does this occur one reason
is because of a lack of information
people simply don't
know that there are differentiations
that they should be looking at that not
everything is exactly the same
and to a certain extent people can be
held
you know less responsible
for that provided that the information
isn't missing because they decided to
disregard it
or because they are sloppy in the way
that they
they handle information they were given
it but didn't pay attention to it
you know here would be an example most
americans know very little about
islam as a a religion
as a sort of culture and civilization
spanning centuries i think
most americans by this point hopefully
do know that there
there's two main divisions within islam
sunni islam which is the largest and
then shia islam there's others as well
you know other distinctions that get
made and within each of them
you can find other further distinctions
that are being made
now let's say that you actually do know
okay there's these two different kinds
of
of muslims and they don't like each
other necessarily
but that's it is that all that you need
to know
about islam in order to
think things through when it comes to
actually dealing with muslims
well um why are things different from
from muslim country to muslim country
why aren't they all exactly the same
because there are distinctions that are
made for example
there are four main legal schools within
sunni islam
and they have different ways of you know
looking at
at the particular issues of reasoning
things out
so if you didn't have that information
you wouldn't know that
now once you actually do acquire that
information
then you can start making better and
better distinctions you can start
thinking things through more carefully
you can start asking the right sorts of
questions
and that leads to the second
oftentimes people have the habit
of stopping short in their research and
this could be because of a lack of
curiosity
or a you know unwillingness to think
things through
or wanting to get things done very very
quickly or being kind of sloppy
it could actually come from a lack of
information about what is research
and how much information is there out
there and what you know
what ought you to be doing as a human
being carrying that sort of stuff
out but very often people will not go
further than they they feel that they
should or further than they feel that
that they need to
uh in order to think about how things
split up how things break down and so
they'll engage in
you know sort of sloppy simplistic
abstract thinking or they'll set up
false dichotomies because they they
don't realize
by going further that there are other
alternatives or they'll
blur things together because they didn't
really think that these are separate
issues
when a little bit more research would
indicate that to them
now a lot of times people don't know
where to go
this is another problem but
again these two kind of go together
they're not researching the lack of
information
they're also consolidated by mental
habits and this is a very important
point
as human beings we are the product of
our actions and choices
and those get consolidated into habits
this is not entirely up to us we are
formed to some degree by
our environment and the the things that
other people provide us as models
um we don't you know it's not as if you
can snap your fingers overnight and quit
whatever habit is that you have
but whether it comes to physical actions
like biting one's fingernails or whether
it comes to emotional responses
or ways of thinking or ways of
approaching things
these are matters of habit and the more
that you do something a particular way
the more it's going to seem natural to
you and the more
other ways of doing it are going to seem
unnatural or they're going to be totally
left out of the picture
so if you get yourself in the habit of
doing these sorts of things
and i think unfortunately that the way
that we educate a lot of the time
tends to produce and reward
some of this cognitive behavior
on a lot of people's parts in part
because i think educators themselves
often don't make good distinctions when
they want to be making them
because we do this a lot of people have
mental habits
that make it difficult for them to not
only make distinctions but to see the
need to make distinctions and
what is the result of that they don't
make the distinctions
and then they wind up in all sorts of
quandaries operas you know literally
where you can't find your way out
when actually if you made the right
distinctions and then followed them
through
you could think your way through
something
i think that emotions also fit in with
this as well
people often have a very strong desire
for things to be simpler than they are
and
i can understand that you know i feel i
fall into that myself
from time to time when i when i over
simplify
in in my personal life but it's
something that we have to resist
if we want to understand reality reality
is complicated
even a single human being is very
complicated
so when it comes to ethics why would we
possibly think that everything could be
reduced to just a simple
list of cut and dried answers
people want that sort of thing but what
they're desiring is something that's
actually not
good for them that's a starting point
being given a code
but that's not really becoming a thinker
who can actually apply
ethical or moral principles to real
cases and successfully
come up with the good moral evaluations
and judgments and then
be able to justify them to other people
to get them on the same
on the same track or to figure out some
of these you know big issues that that
keep coming up over and over and over
again
which we have to address so
all of these are things that if you want
to think about where you
actually stand with this would be good
to
focus on do you feel like things
ought to be simpler than they are do you
feel a kind of repugnance when being
asked to make distinctions
is that coming about because of emotions
or is that coming about because of
mental habits
have you actually sought out information
when you wind up in some sort of
quandary
do you know that it's up to you to go
out and look for answers
that the answers are not just going to
pop into your head
you may be lucky enough to have some
people near you who actually see the
problem that you're in and say
oh i've had this sort of problem myself
but most of the time as an adult you
actually have to seek out the answers
that you need
and making distinctions is going to be
an absolutely irreplaceable tool
in your arsenal in order to be able to
do that
so
if i had to close on anything i would
just say
you can't get by without making good
distinctions
the more that the more that you practice
that the more that you get used to doing
that
the better you're going to be from
situation to situation to situation from
subject matter to subject matter to
subject matter
because this is an extremely important
cognitive skill
not only for ethics but for anything
that you're going to go into
and i'm willing to bet whatever it is
that you're interested in whatever it is
that you're studying if it's not ethics
you've probably learned how to make
distinctions in that
area if you're really interested in
cooking you don't think all spices are
the same right
so you actually make distinctions and
you say well this is for this case this
is for this case
learn how to transfer that skill from
one context to the other
and you're putting yourself in really
good stead to be able to handle this
sort of thing